adidas is the second biggest sports
company in the world and dominates
several markets around the world
despite this vast success they have not
been able to penetrate the Indian market
so why did a scale in India and will
they eventually be able to succeed in
India maker stick around till end to
find out
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus so TVs was
actually founded by a Tov Adi Dassler
who sold for shoes in his local market
that he made in his mother's laundry
room his brother Rudolph rejoined the
business in 1924 after he returned from
World War one it was not an easy journey
for the two there were several issues
like unreliable electricity in such
cases one person who peddle a stationary
bike in order to generate power and
other person would run the equipment the
Dazzler brothers were really focused on
spite of like shoes that can be used for
several athletic events they wanted a
transition from the old model using
heavy metal spikes into canvas and
rubber and in 1936 adi was able to
persuade Jesse Owens to use his handmade
spiked shoes in Summer Olympics of 1936
and this brought world fame - dasu
corporation five-time World War two
rolled around they were selling 200
shoes every single year during World War
two
use forces almost completely destroyed
their Factory but they were able to
convince US forces but they were only
interested in manufacturing sport shoes
the occupy American forces actually
became major buyers of the - their shoes
and they brought it back to America in
1947 the brothers actually split and
Rudolf Dassler create a company called
Buddha which is later rebranded as Puma
and a top-dollar created adidas there's
an urban legend that says that adidas
stands for all-day
at dream about sports but it's actually
just a toff desert nicknamed Adi along
with last name Dazzler which forms
adidas in 1952 it have acquired the
iconic three type logo from a finished
footwear brand car whose force and he
was able to buy it for just two balls of
whiskey and 1600 euros
I've cried he died the company actually
struggled for several decades until tapi
bought her in 1989 he bought the company
for 140
3.9 million euros and he was a
specialist in saving companies from
bankruptcy
he moved production overseas use Madonna
as marketing I was able to create the
adidas that we know today
but unfortunately later he was put in
prison for match-fixing but before he
went to prison he was able to make the
company profitable and sustainable since
then adidas has gone around the world
made huge brand deals and today here the
second biggest sports company in the
world Ballard over fifty billion dollars
so why was his sporting behemoth not
able to break into the indeed market
first of all there was a plethora of
counterfeits going around in the Indian
market these are sold through Amazon
Flipkart or Snapdeal which are large
e-commerce retailers in India most of
the time these counterfeits had a
terrible quality and were priced much
cheaper and so many people got scammed
by them but there was also a handful of
really good counterfeits that were
actually comparable to quality of Adidas
shoes and people were fine with these
they didn't care that it was a
counterfeit as long as it was good
quality and many people didn't even know
that these were counterfeits Adidas
brand production managers and e-commerce
sites really try to buckle down on these
counterfeits but very hard as it was
hard to tell whether they were
counterfeit or not they would use
pictures of real authentic shoes in the
listing and then sell customers the fake
ones and the problem was the good
quality counterfeits actually received
good reviews which made a hard to
distinguish from authentic products and
the ones that didn't have significant
amounts of bad reviews were easily able
to cheat the system
Snapdeal attempted to incorporate AI
which just came the pictures of these
listings and see if they're genuine
products but the problem was that
genuine pictures were used in the
listings so this really didn't help and
not to mention the physical stores that
were selling counterfeits you really
couldn't tell which store was selling
them as they were often called discount
stores and there are local stores as
well so you would have to go very deep
into villages in order to be able to
find these doors
these stores would sell counterfeits of
Adidas shoes and knockoff brand shoes
called a bebas and these shoes were all
much cheaper than authentic Adidas shoes
which made it hard for DJ's to compete
now
why would the public turn to
counterfeits and even prefer them over
the original product the answer is the
original products were way too expensive
to start off with India's poorest people
live off just 45 cents per day so dieter
shoes were way too expensive for them
only 20 percent of India's population
mix up the English speaking upper-class
this means that only 240 million people
out of India's population or actually
fit for Adidas market this is a smaller
market than America not to mention that
even most of these people only had a
fraction of the wealth of most Americans
on top of all of this there are high
import tariffs which inflate the prices
even more it's pretty clear why you
would get pretty bad sales when you're
trying to sell the same product for a
higher price to a poorer population
furthermore adidas underestimated cost
that I would take in India like most
Western companies do when expanded to
other countries they thought that the
cost of labour would be incredibly cheap
and didn't actually true for less
qualified positions but when you're
looking for seasoned senior executives
there are Priya secures and had to pay
them pretty penny also the real estate
in India is a lot more expensive than
most American places so you're building
american-sized stores you're going to be
paying a lot more for them this again
and play the price of the shoes and put
it out of the budget of most people and
this is a problem with almost all
Western stores which is a lack of
localization ideas came in and put
stores just like New Jersey into India
and this does not work in India and
really benefited competitors the
competitors were able to pay less for
leases electricity and salary and this
really allowed them to offer cheaper
shoes and adidas in India there's too
many ways to break into market the first
way is to offer the cheapest solution
and second way is to win the trust of
the public but building a trust is a
long time intensive process but it is
important to success of a company as it
creates customer loyalty and adidas
really had topic in is chancellor public
as indians preferred indian goods now of
course there's some national pride that
goes into this but the main reason is
because locals think that it's better
for them spend money and give it to
other locals do you would rather help a
local shop owner that make a Western
corporate giant richer as a result the
western-style stores really just ran up
costs and inflated the price of the
product and this turned away voice of
people and there's a huge underlying
issue which is that most Indians don't
even wear shoes on a regular basis even
people who have corporate jobs simply
wear dress shoes to work but then when
they're going on with family or friends
they were sandals or flip-flops Indians
simply don't work casual shoes on a
regular basis like Americans do it would
have really benefited eatest it did
localize their stores and sold more
sandals and flip-flops
instead of casual shoes plopping Western
stores into new markets simply never
works and I'm not sure why companies
have figured us out yet and something
else that really hurt adidas is growth
in India was her subsidary Reebok ideas
had bought Reebok in 2005 for 3.8
billion dollars now Reebok was an
underperformer in the global market but
not in India they had a head start over
their competitors in India and I'm
actually able to do pretty well this
will all change when a man named Priya
the man in charge of Reebok India would
take the company in new direction now
ideas Barbie back in 2005 but they don't
actually merge until 2011 and their
operations are kept separate Prem renew
the adidas would eventually merge with
Reebok and when that happened he wanted
to be the man in charge of Adidas India
and as a result he tried to do stuff
that would impress his superiors at this
point
adidas was slowly entering the market
and a pram really want a Reebok to beat
adidas no work assure that I did his
officials that he was able to the
company in the right direction
now there's nothing wrong with this this
is actually good competition even within
a brand is really good as it pushes
forward innovation but the problem was
this didn't lead to innovation this led
to dumb choices that made Reebok look
better on paper he really expanded
Reebok across India very rapidly going
from just 100 stores to 800 stores in a
matter of years as he did this he
sacrificed the margins and Bob
ability of all these doors he imposed hi
franchise caught and convinced owners to
open franchise doors by promising that
Reebok would deal with any excess
inventory in the stores but he didn't do
that and this made franchise owners
really mad and they stopped making the
franchise payments but these issues
would arise till much later and to the
adidas officials it looked at Primus
demure great job expanding Reebok all
across India and getting a lot more
franchise feed as well as a result an
Adidas and Reebok combined and made
ideas India brain was put in charge but
eventually the irregularities would
start to pop up and adidas would figure
out what happened and praying was fired
for undisclosed reasons so you might
have gotten other bad stuff too like
faking numbers I did his did file a
criminal complaint against them sooner
probably is more to the story
preme turned around and found two cases
against adidas one for defamation
another one for recovery of past news
but that's all irrelevant whether he did
impress this appears or actually thought
I was right idea to expand Reebok in the
end he has left Reebok and ruins and
really hurt adidas and I would say that
these internal issues were the main
reason parties failure in India despite
this rough storm India and vast internal
issues ideas continue to sell shoes in
India but they would appoint a new
leader Dave Thomas who had completely
saved the company in India Hugh make
originals popular in India in 2014 when
you came in original only made up three
percent of the revenue but by 2017 there
are accounting for over 10 percent
many of the local executives told him
that wouldn't work as the idea was very
dirty and why shoes just wouldn't be
manageable but he had on his left one
opportunity slip away in Japan
compression were by listening to locals
so he wasn't going to let this one go he
went with his gut and it turned out to
be a great success he made sure that
what he needs enter the brand new shoe
market that adidas was their first
choice he was able to do this by
marketing to local tastes and acting on
popular trends he didn't just recklessly
add you
stores are formed to us tastes he
confirmed it to what the Indian public
wanted and that's really all he needed
to do and just two years ago ideas
became a first for sure brand in India
to reach the 1000 or revenue mark and
adidas has continued to grow since then
in India adidas is a large sports
company that's very popular especially
in soccer
however they have some trouble entering
the Indian market as her shoes were not
localized their shoes were too expensive
there were several counterfeits and
there were several internal issues as
well but under new leadership adidas has
really excelled in India being able to
at India to its vast portfolio maybe
after seeing all this a great success
for adidas in India
Nike might jump in as well ball in time
hotel but that's why I have for you guys
and why ideas failed in India make your
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this to be the MEC drop a like
and get to me subscribe me PXE more
music just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]